[Music]
check out David and Victoria Beckham's
kids front and center as mom and dad
pose in the background with Jesse Tyler
Ferguson Jesse actually posted this shot
from the set of Modern Family David
avatar against some major parenting
points right there yeah nicely done so
what's it like being part of this famous
family well it's our look at growing up
back up me and my wife you know we're
very hands-on our family our children
always come first so it's simple as that
how would you best describe what it's
like growing up Beckham I feel like it
has its ups and downs I feel like I get
opportunities that in most people my age
don't get but like I can't do what most
18 year olds do like I can't go out
party all the time like I used like I
have to work yeah actually all those
Beckham boys are working we're close a
photographer who just put out his first
book 14 year old Romeo reportedly got
paid 58 thousand dollars for one day of
work as a Burberry model and Cruz who's
12 well he's a little people in the
making he's even got his own music video
with the boys you know there's a lot of
energy 24 hours but then you know a
little girl comes into the mix and you
know she sweetens the whole house up the
proud parents post everything on social
media but there is a downside of being
so famous the paparazzi is always
tracking you guys there's no worse
there's the it's just the black lens is
I get such anxiety from that like oh I
hate it
and growing up Beckham does come with a
few rules for us we just want the kids
to be happy healthy treat other people
how they want to be treating themselves
be kind give back
[Music]
you